Ist er jetzt so streben an?
Ja jetzt okay, ja ich habe es vorher ein bisschen verkackt
Ich hatte nicht die falschen settings an und hatte ein paar Sachen nicht gestartet
Der wallhack war nicht an
Ne ne das war nicht verpackt, ich habe absichtlich ausgemacht
So Leute was wir heute machen
Ich zeige es euch nochmal kurz
Also ich zeige euch mal wie es aktuell aussieht
Ich zeige euch wie es aktuell aussieht und dann erkläre ich was wir versuchen heute zu
machen
Allerdings muss ich sagen ich bin jetzt nicht der, also ihr wisst erstens sage ich nicht
der allergrößte java scriptheld bin und mit leaflet habe ich auch noch nicht allzu viel
gemacht
Aber das kriegen wir schon gebacken irgendwie
Ich erkläre euch mal was ich will und dann gucken wir mal wie wir das machen können
Kannst ja mal testen wenn du willst was denn
Achso
Diese was was hä, diese csv api von dpd gibt als plz für alle zwischenschattionen
Übrigens des empfängers
Ja und wo ist das problem
Achso meinst du das
Achso ich dachte das steht einfach ich dachte das geht nur wenn man die plz selbst übergibt
weil auf der webseite muss man auch die plz eintragen
Keine Ahnung war es auch immer da bei dpd los ist kein schimmer
Ja ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie es aktuell aussieht der versand trackzor das ist ja der
versand trackzor hier
Und was ist folgendes
Na ja kann es gleich wieder zugehen
Oh die abfragen gehen aber schnell diesmal
Krass
Telecom geht übrigens nicht ich habe jetzt auch gecheckt warum Telecom nicht funktioniert
Telecom äh nicht Tele, warum sage ich ja hier mal Telecom anstatt DHL
Die sehen sich doch nicht mal ansatzweise ähnlich
DHL funktioniert nicht weil ich mein tägliches api limit erreicht habe
Also ich die ganze zeit im hintergrund laufen habe 5000 abgefragt oder so
Die dating app mit der gps mit den gps apps war auch geil
Da gab es doch diese was war das
Gab es da nicht diese sache mit der militärübung
Wo dann quasi die einen waren das die schweden
Wo die wo sie über tinder festgestellt haben
Wo sich die schweden versteckt haben bei irgendeiner militärübung
Einfach auf tinder geguckt und festgestellt in diesem ort sind irgendwie 30.000 schweden
Das muss wohl die militär einheit sein
Habe ich irgendwo news gelesen mit irgendeiner militärübung
Wo die quasi in anführungsweise die angreifer die defender über tinder gefunden haben
Nordfond sehr gut die stimmt ja auch nicht
Oh ich muss ich muss verhaha ich muss meinen meinen pepega board starten
Ohne pepega board kriege ich ja die ganzen fragen nicht nicht mit
Sekunde pepega board starten cool story max da brauchen wir echt ein
eigenes emote für wupp wupp story
So es ist jetzt gestartet
Da ist es
Ok die fragen sind relativ alt die schmeißen wir mal weg kurz
So übrigens huge sprain man kann einfach die taste gedrückt halten
Schreibt mal bitte eine nachricht an mich ob die jetzt ankommt
Wenn die nicht ankommen muss ich noch mal neu starten
Nee funktioniert nicht funktioniert nicht
Ach ich weiß warum es nicht funktioniert Weil die verbindung zur twitch api abgekackt
ist
Wir können wir können es übrigens jetzt mal hier drüber starten
Moment was hat der für schmerz jetzt
Muss man das so machen
Ihr müsst hier irgendeinen Mist exportieren dann funktioniert es auch
Was hatten wir das letzte mal schon
Ich starte es jetzt über die idee und gut ist ich weiß nicht was der grad für schmerzen
hat
Wahrscheinlich ist das falsche projekt ich glaube das ist ja ja
Ich glaube das ist das falsche projekt was ich grad starte
Ist der qualsor qualt im hintergrund rum
Nö das ist das richtige projekt ja bonkersmoke
Ist mal ein meme board abgekackt
Geht doch
So und jetzt noch mal kurz schreiben bitte an mich eine message und gucken ob es funktioniert
Ah ja funktioniert schon
Ab heute mal vms von virtualbox zu hyper v umgezogen und die starten drastisch schneller
Kannst du dir erklären wie das sein kann
Wahrscheinlich weil es microsoft besser kann als oracle
Allerdings grafische sachen sollten eigentlich unter unter hyper v also es sei denn du virtualisierst
windows unter windows aber wenn du linux unter windows virtualisierst
Das ist angeblich angeblich ich habe es nie ausprobiert ja
Ist das mit mit hyper v nicht so der wahnsinn
Funktioniert park
Kannst du rider empfehlen also ich finde es ziemlich gut das ist auch die einzige alternative
so wirklich wenn man unter anderen plattformen dort net entwickeln will als unter windows
Unter windows hast du noch visual studio allerdings ansonsten was hast du da visual studio code
oder mac visual studio mac
Also ich finde es ganz gut was ich bisher gesehen habe das einzige was mir auf den keks geht
ist ganz schön langsam könnte aber auch an meiner vm liegen wobei ich muss sagen auf
der arbeit habe ich auf dem notebook auch und da ist es nicht in der vm oder ist es
auch langsam
Mails, das könnte ich echt mal machen da könnte ich nämlich den mails gerne ausprobieren
Ok also ich zeige euch jetzt mal was ich vor habe und zwar mein versand mein versandtracksor
der ist ja mittlerweile in so weit ausgereift dass das reine versandtracks gut funktioniert
und was natürlich cool wäre wenn man eine map hätte wo man wo man sieht die die einzelne
station und und die zielstation dass man quasi ungefähr einschätzen kann wie weit
das paket weg ist aktuell ist es noch nicht sonderlich advanced wenn ich jetzt da drauf
klicke sag mal hier ich klicke irgendwie auf auf mal oder so dann lädt er erst mal eine
weile vor sich hin und dann lädt er die stadt ohne marker drauf ohne was ohne alles ja das
ist das ist das bringt nicht sonderlich viel außer dass man dass man schon immer sehen
und konnte das chemie park in mal keine ahnung das bringt es bringt nicht wirklich so und
ich habe mir gedacht wir bauen das ganze jetzt um und zwar dass wenn man hier auf irgendeinen
link klickt zu einer stadt dass er sich dann alle dass er sich dann erst mal abruft welche
koordinaten die stadt hat hier zum beispiel freiburg und mal also alle alle städte die
hier in der sendeverfolgung drin sind und dann nimmt er eine map also nur mal so wie
ich mir das vorstelle nimmt eine map von sagen wir von deutschland so eine map malt so marker
an die stelle wo die zwischenstationen sind und dann macht er eine linie zwischen den
markern und dann und jetzt wird es kommt richtig jetzt wird es richtig pro und dann soll er
die linie noch animieren dass quasi die linie quasi vom abfallsort zum zielort zu über
die marker geht also richtig richtig huge huge brain projekt was wir jetzt haben ich
glaube gar nicht dass es so kompliziert ist ich habe mir im vorfeld schon ein bisschen
angeguckt heute mittag wie man das machen könnte kommt auch rgb na das bauen wir ins
mime board ein rgb ok starten wir erstmal visual studio code kodra fort ein ok da haben
wir uns zack jetzt müssen wir noch unseren live server starten und ich bin der totale
nupe ich habe letztens den live server voll vollkommen falsch eingerichtet kann ich mich
auch zeigen was ich verkehrt gemacht habe live server config ich habe hier eingestellt
live server settings der soll den proxy benutzen das ist vollkommener bullshit der muss den
proxy überhaupt nicht benutzen weil das komplett ohne proxy funktioniert wenn ich jetzt hier
reingehe und einfach eine taste drücke dann die ach so ich muss ihn erstmal einschalten
ja ja und jetzt kackt es wieder ab sei denn noch da ich glaube ich glaube obs hat es
wieder verkackt jetzt so und jetzt sollte er eigentlich reloaden ich glaube ich weiß
was ich verkehrt gemacht habe muss hier in der extension noch einstellen das da da muss
ich nämlich hier einstellen das habe ich nämlich bei mir vorhin vielleicht auch gemacht
aber ich habe jetzt hier die aktuelle server adress ist das und live server adress ist
das und wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe dann funkt es auch seht ihr reload passt auf
man sieht es jetzt nicht aber es hat funktioniert ihr seht er reloadet wenn ich speichere das
ist sehr nice das kann man gebrauchen so also als erstes wo ich mal ein bisschen mein map
gedöns aufräumen weil ich zeige es euch mal es ist wirklich nicht schön wie ich das
gemacht habe wir machen das wir machen den versandtracks auch mal ein bisschen kleiner
der versandtracks auch kann ohne probleme so sein dass wir ein bisschen vom editor sehen
so map ist groß genug im endeffekt so das ist dann fast schon fast eher so ipad größe
dann bei ipad so was gibt es eine api kommt auf den anbieter an dhl hat eine api dpd hat
eine api ups hat eine api hermes hat so eine so eine halbe api hermes haben zwar keine
offizielle api allerdings das was sie in ihrer webseite abrufen die chasen werte sind sind
ziemlich simpel quasi ab zu ab zu zu zu zu stelzen die einzigen die wir wirklich web
scrapen müssen wird amazon sein ich habe einfach nur irgendwas dran geschrieben leute
steht einfach nur irgendwas dran das ist noch nicht meine tracking nummer von mir plus
ist plus meine api aufrufen für dhl sind sind beschränkt das heißt ich krieg nix
guckt hier ups ach nee ich habe den dhl tracker sogar rausgenommen amazon amazon will nicht
dass man darauf zugreift glaube ich amazon ist ja eh recht restriktiv was die machen
mit der dhl api werden wir das ganz einfach machen ich registriere mich entweder bei dhl
also mit fake sachen aber das reicht ja dann kriege ich zumindest schon mal 1000 api requests
am tag oder oder ich mache mir einfach 20 fake accounts ich mache mir 20 fake accounts
und dann verschlüssel ich die api hieß so dass die keiner sieht in der anwendung also
jeder mit hirn wird die trotzdem sehen aber dhl sieht er nicht dann nehme ich random immer
einen raus super super sie kritt
dürfte verraten wir natürlich glaube ich sehe hier gerade was ich habe ja noch eis hier stehen
bevor wir richtig anfangen muss ich mal kurz ne runde eis futtern
also das heißt wenn ihr noch irgendwas wissen wollt oder irgendwie allgemeines zeug schlammern
wollt bevor wir in keine ahnung fünf minuten mit mit javascript progress anfangen haut
raus egal was
wenigstens in dem halben Jahr haben wir dann max leaks ja habe ich das gibt es auch schon
ganz viele leaks
was findest du denn an der google maps api kacke nichts die google maps api ist ziemlich
gut das problem ist an der google maps api also für den anwendungszweck hier jetzt dass
ich den api key brauche der beschränkt ist und wenn ich den api key bundle mit meiner
anwendung dann können die ersten fünf leute am tag ihre ihre sachen aufrufen und der restliche
die restlichen leute den restlichen tag nicht mehr
wie das heißt aktuell verwende ich lieflet lieflet ist so ein javascript ding für maps
das kann aber alle möglichen backends das ist open street maps das ist open street maps
ganz normales open street maps
wie findest du es in der übersicht zusätzlich zur stadt die entfernung zum lieferort in
kilometer hinzuschreiben
findest du eine gute idee
erinnere mich nochmal dran wenn wir den anderen kram fertig haben
ich schreibs dir mal auf
erstmal mal den anderen kram
erstmal machen wir das so dass wir hier marker reinmalen und animierte linien und zeug
was ihr warum
wollte meinen pc abklären hab hardwarerad auf twitter gefragt wie es mit 8700k aussieht
8700k ist outdated
und jeder meint ich soll amd kaufen ja würde ich auch machen
wenn ich mir jetzt einen neuen desktop rechner kaufen würde würde ich mir auch amd rechner
kaufen
beste
sebaro fanboyn bringt nix einfach das kaufen wo preisleistungsmäßig am besten ist fanboyn
bringt doch bei herstellern nix
guckt euch mal an die ganzen call of duty fanboys
was haben die denn davon dass sie activision beziehungsweise call of duty fanboyn
das einzige was sie davon haben ist dass sie von activision besonders gemolken werden
warum amd weil ich der meinung bin das preisleistungsmäßig gerade einfach den besseren rechner zusammen
bauen kann mit amd
entweder ein bisschen mehr geld bei amd und deutlich mehr kerne
oder weniger geld für gleich viel kerne und mehr leistung oder sag mal so
und unterschiedliche unterschiedliche ebenden auf den stufen dazwischen
wirklich einen grund für intel gibt es aktuell nicht
es sei denn ist der einzige grund der mir einfällt
man hat irgendwie noch einen board und will einfach eine neuere cpu drauf machen
allerdings ist das gerade bei intel schwierig die haben ja alle futzleine neuen socke
aber amd sieht das alles aus
so alles ist gleich
so alles ist weg auf geht's
ok also so das erste was wir machen ist
und das erste was wir machen müssen ich zeige euch mal mein java script code der für
die mapgeschichte zuständig ist das ist nicht nicht schön ja aber es ist ja es ist auch
nicht so viel
das eigentliche problem ist typisches javascript problem
es ist asynchron mit callbacks
was ist das ppega chat heute was ist da los
was wird im chat los heute das ist ja eindeutig kein cute chat heute
das ist das ist richtig ppega chat
es grenzt teilweise schon an kappa pride chat was da grad so los ist
heute chat
running low on cuties ja genau
typische javascript geschichte
es ist asynchron allerdings asynchron mit
ich warte jetzt noch bis der erste anfängt mit asynchron oder irgendwie sowas heute heute
ist der chat ja wirklich
bisschen merkwürdig
und das problem bei der ganzen geschichte ist wenn das hier asynchron ist
also asynchron mit callback dann wird es ganz schön schwierig so sachen zu machen wie
erst mal alle koordinaten einsammeln und dann den kram auf der karte malen
deswegen ist glaube ich eine sache die wir erst mal am anfang machen müssen ist das
hier das hier so umzubasteln dass es halbwegs
synchron läuft
jetzt holt er noch die bob ascii arts raus
so und jetzt gucken wir erst mal was es für möglichkeiten gibt mit leaflet
wie man wie man marker wie man marker mit leaflet macht
also ich weiß dass es marker heißt weil ich schon mal irgendwann verwendet habe
marker add to map
das muss ich mal speichern weil wir brauchen ja für jeden punkt
wir brauchen ja für jeden für jeden punkt auf der map
den wir also für jeden für jeden zwischenstopp
brauchen wir auf der map einen marker
so das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt erst mal
müssen wir jetzt erst mal einen array basteln wo alle koordinaten drin sind
ich nenne es mal irgendwie points oder so wo alle koordinaten drin sind die wir markieren
müssen
so und damit wir die koordinaten abfragen können
rooting apes habe ich schon geguckt gibt es auch von open street map
was was eigenes was kostenloses allerdings
ich habe mir das überlegt ich werde keine ich werde keine routing machen
ich werde einfach einfach zwischen den punkten eine linie
eine linie malen
ganz ganz einfach
übrigens habe ich euch schon erzählt dass wenn ihr ein amazon prime account habt
moment wo ist man sehr laut wo ist man sehr laut
wenn ein amazon prime account habt könnt ihr die ganzen kostenlos mit eurem twitch account
verknüpfen und dadurch bekommt ihr einmal im monat
die möglichkeit euren lieblings streamer zu unterstützen mit einem tier 1 sub
der euch nichts kostet wenn ihr dem streamer alles bringt was ein normaler sub bringen
würde ohne dass ihr was dafür bezahlen müsst also im prinzip könnte man eigentlich sagen
alle die mit twitch prime suppen haben massive iq und huge brain
feifert ja übrigens da hab ich hab ich euch auch mal schon gezeigt hier extra neues emote
irgendwie mag ich das lol wie so und jetzt jetzt zeige ich euch mal die krasse java script
hacks nur hier leute huge java script hacks und zwar wenn ihr das problem habt das euer
code also was ich jetzt machen will was ich jetzt machen will ist folgendes ich will
abfragen also was das hier macht noch mal kurz zur erklärung muss ich vielleicht erzählen
was das hier macht ist das löst auf einen ort also sowas wie sowas wie freiburg in deutschland
löst das auf zu koordinaten auf einer map geocoding
macht er macht er macht er im browser wir haben es letztes jahr im backend gemacht aber
ich hab gedacht komm ich machs jetzt mal im browser weil es der erst mal auf den ersten
blick einfacher ist monka js und das löst hier sowas wie wie freiburg de löst es zu
den zu den längen breiten grad koordinaten auf wie brauche ich dass ich die auf der map
markieren kann hier ne hier sieht man es und dann setzt noch dann setzt noch den titel
von der map wenn er abgefragt hat so was ich jetzt machen will ist im prinzip ich will
sowas sagen wie points push und dann da die koordinaten rein so wer hat hier eine glorreiche
idee wo das problem ist ich hab es ja grad schon ich hab es ja grad schon gespoilert
was könnten das für ein problem geben der macht im hintergrund jedes mal nen get zu
der geocode api und sobald das fertig ist führt er das hier aus und pusht das in das
array rein so und ich hab es ja ich hab es ja grad im prinzip schon gespoilert das problem
ist einmal natürlich javascript da hat er hat er jojo folgfolge ganz recht ich brauch
noch so ich brauche unbedingt ich hab leider kein monka javascript ich hab nur monka java
am start was könnten wir für javascript das müssen wir mal kurz machen was könnten
wir als javascript für einen was ist ein schönes symbol für javascript was verbindet
man mit javascript woodface der ist universal der ist universal the golden boy der ist universal
dp heads ein kack auf dem dp ja das eigentlich haben wir schon genug alternativen ne ne ach
keine ahnung im prinzip für javascript ist der eigentlich ausreichend wir haben ja wir
haben ja eigentlich ist der javascript nicht schlecht der monka smoke nicht schlecht für
javascript so das problem ist dass wenn er hier die koordinaten abfragt dass die dann
in der falschen reinfolge im in diesem array landen nämlich je nachdem was jetzt zuerst
welcher request zuerst fertig ist und das ist natürlich doof deswegen und jetzt zeige ich
euch die richtig krassen javascript hacks source hacks die die huge checks was man machen
kann wenn man den javascript asynchron callback code hat wie man den umwandeln kann in was
was man halbwegs synchron verwenden kann mit assync await und zwar geht das folgendermaßen
wir müssen wir machen erstmal eine neue funktion noch mal geocode geocode so und da war jetzt
folgendes auch das ding braucht das ding ein parameter ja das braucht die das braucht die
location als als parameter so und jetzt kommt huge big brain also return new promise und da
kann man jetzt drin das resolve cancel die error wie wie ist das reject reject genau so was man
damit machen kann ist so was hier kann man warten also auf so was kann man warten und ich kann
jetzt einfach den ganzen krempel hinnehmen weiß nicht ob das eine schöne variante ist aber das
ist halt javascript da ist wenig da ist wenig schön excellent alex alex excellent und man kann
einfach sagen ok jetzt rufen wir den ganzen kram ab location wollen wir abrufen aber nur
debug ausgabe das war man hier wieder weg das war man auch alles weg und jetzt sagen wir nur
resolve und dann die koordinaten und nu und nu können wir hier nämlich an der stelle sagen a weight auf geocode
location das funktioniert jetzt ich habe essen vergessen oder klug gehabt
so und jetzt kann ich dann nämlich darauf warten was es möglich macht die ganze sache
ungefähr halbwegs synchron abzuarbeiten das macht natürlich langsamer ja da kann jetzt nicht
fünf requests gleichzeitig machen da kann er so parallel immer request machen aber wir wissen
zumindest dass die requests in in der richtigen reinfolge reinkommen man könnte es komplizierter
machen man könnte komplizierter machen man könnte die die request parallel durchführen und sie im
nachhinein wieder in die richtige reinfolge sortieren wenn man das irgendwie irgendwo ran
festmachen kann aber ich glaube so ist erstmal die einfache variante so ist gleichzeitig und parallel
doch was habe ich was habe ich erzählt was auch immer zumindest jetzt machen wir das hier halbwegs
halbwegs synchron an der stelle also noch nicht aber gleich sobald wir darauf zugreifen ich habe
mir gedacht wir machen das jetzt wir machen das jetzt so dass ich mir ein so habe ich gesagt ja
gut manchmal erzähle ich viel über den tag lang ist ich meinte wahrscheinlich synchron und einmal
parallel points kann dann konst sein achso ja das ist übrigens voll fail dass ich das also ich
ich bin auch so gewöhnt wahr zu machen weil ich sonst immer c-sharp programmieren war ist
natürlich mittlerweile in java script nicht mehr nicht mehr das ding also wahrscheinlich
kann es tatsächlich sogar konst sein das stimmt da muss ich mich auch mal dran gewöhnen dass man
und die zeug und dass das hier kann im prinzip auch konst sein gibt es den unterschied zwischen
wahr und let also ich glaube einmal hast du das problem mit wahr dass du dass du irgendwie
dein scope vollmüllst also wahr ist eigentlich gescoped also sprich wenn ich jetzt hier wenn
ich jetzt sowas hier mache und da drin eine variable anlege dann gilt die eigentlich auch nur hier es
sei denn ich definiere sie vorher ich glaube bei let ist es so aber da müsst ihr müsst ihr mich
müsste mich korrigieren die java script ich glaube let gilt immer nur in der funktion wo es definiert
ist oder zumindest habe ich mal gelesen dass man mit wahr seine seinen scope vollmüllt
man verwendet einfach kein wahr und man ist gut to go ja das habe ich mir das muss ich mir mal
merken ich ich ich verwende immer automatisch wahr weil halt im back end überall wahr verwendest
das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen nervig kurz konzentrieren also was muss ich was muss ich
jetzt machen ich muss jetzt ich brauche jetzt eine schleife es ist schon mal witzig wie viele
schleifen es in java script gibt es gibt eine normale vorschleife es gibt eine for each schleife
die dann so aussieht das ist die extension es gibt einen vor innen und in vor oft und in dem
fall brauchen wir einen vor oft ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so genau warum aber vor oft ist
die normale vor each schleife das java script logik so und jetzt packen wir das da rein geht
sowas eigentlich geht sowas eigentlich wird das dann in die schleife wieder neu wieder neu beschrieben
oder darfst die variable global nur einmal geben mit konst ne na das nur im scope im scope darf
es halt nicht mehr ändern danach ok so das war mal eine schleife über über alle sachen von
shipment ach so moment das habe ich in der funktion gar nicht drin eine funktion habe ich
nur die history drin ich sollte übrigens mal nicht entry nennen sondern vielleicht mal sondern
vielleicht mal vielleicht mal history oder so history nennen wir das mal weil es ist die die
die history vom paket halt sende verfolgung infos so das muss ich hier oben noch umstellen
dass das überhaupt da rein gehauen wird und wird mal zeit als ich den graben umstelle da
ich blick ich blick hier in meinem ganzen java script css gedürnt überhaupt gar nicht mehr
durch pop-up map jetzt hat es doch eben irgendwo und pop-up map aktuell kriege ich hier bloß die
aktuelle history und ich brauche nicht nur die aktuelle history ich brauche das komplette das
komplette also die kompletten versand infos von so einem eintrag und nicht nur den history
eintrag das mit history stimmt übrigens auch nicht jetzt einfach so egal wir brauchen das
wahrscheinlich eh nicht so und jetzt muss ich machen wir machen das mal weg das brauche ich
nehme ich glaube ich gar nicht braucht nur nur die nur die sendung so und jetzt haben wir eine
schleife über jeden eintrag in der history also sprich über jeden eintrag hier also jeden jeden
einzelnen und für jeden einzelnen punkt wo eine location drinne ist für jeden eintrag wo es eine
location gibt ach so moment wie geht das noch mal javascript javascript filter jedoch irgendwie
so filter sowas da ist das javascript konform ja ok für jeden history eintrag der eine stadt
dran stehen hat also der quasi eine location dran stehen hat fragen wir jetzt ab wo das ganze also
die koordinaten wir gucken wir gucken uns mal an ob das auch ob das prinzipiell auch funktioniert
ein bisschen bisschen debug ausgabe gucken wir mal ob es klappt oh
jetzt geht's also was kriegen wir als antwort wir kriegen unsere unsere koordinaten auf der
world map ja genau hier guckt lenkrad breitengrad 47 7,8 also 48 7,8 das funktioniert an der stelle
wir machen jetzt noch mal eine sache ich finde es ein bisschen blöd dass der wir rufen alles ab was
er findet und neben e hardcoded immer den ersten das heißt wir müssen jetzt mal gucken ob man das
irgendwie limitieren kann weil dann werden wir wahrscheinlich auch langsamer getrosselt
ah hier limit eins
müssen wir noch ich habe nämlich gesehen dass man in dem dass man hier custom custom query parameter
angeben kann was der jedes mal mit gibt da hier geocoding query parameters und da oben drin
da sagen wir ihm nämlich der soll limit auf eins setzen wir gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
boah ist das lahm ich glaube wir sind schon getrosselt aber es gibt nur noch eins als
antwort das ist doch schon mal es gibt noch eins als antwort das ist gut das braucht weniger
bandbreite bei denen ja ok ok damit kann ich leben gut also wir kriegen noch eins als antwort
zurück das ist ok dass es ausreichend passt alle ruhr partners gut jetzt haben wir das
ganz abgefragt das heißt hier haben wir jetzt unsere koordinaten drinnen da haben wir jetzt
unsere koordinaten drinnen so jetzt kann ich doch mal testweise auf der map ein paar
marker malen lassen und gucken ob das funktioniert warum hätten alle javascript immer so weil
spaß macht das ist genauso wie warum hätten alle java als spaß macht man sollte das nehmen was
sinnvoll ist ja es gibt es gibt viel schwachsinn javascript es gibt aber viel schwachsinn auch in
anderen programmier sprachen wobei so javascript hat schon ein paar sachen da würde man nicht
unbedingt damit rechnen ja aber eins ganz ehrlich die bleibt ja gar nichts anderes übrig wenn du
web anwendung machen willst als javascript bis die ganzen web assembly geschichten wirklich
massentauglich sehen wird noch ein bisschen dauern so schön so schön blazer jetzt auch ist
du hast beispielsweise web assembly immer noch keinen direkten dom zugriff und sowas also es
wird noch ein bisschen dauern also aktuell kommst du an javascript nicht nicht vorbei und bis
weep assembly endlich was taugt das wird sich wird noch ein bisschen dauern einfach krasses pap
machen pap bringt dir nichts wenn du was im browser machen willst im browser gibt es javascript und
theoretisch auf web assembly aber das ist nicht noch nicht reif macht await in der for loop nicht
problem ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich mache das jetzt so wie man es gerade einfällt
wie man es machen könnte ok jetzt machen wir mal einen marker wir machen jetzt mal einen marker
wir machen jetzt ein marker auf der map
wir machen mal ein marker auf der map
dort wo mal wo wir abgefragt haben probieren wir mal aus
wer marker am start ich muss ich muss noch so um ich muss auf jeden fall so um weil sonst
muss ich jedes mal mehr rein raus kreuen das ist natürlich auch nicht nicht nicht weiß
als letzter schluss ja ok also das das das eigentliche funktioniert schon unser ziel
ist ja wir möchten wir möchten eine linie animieren auf der map so und da habe ich vorhin
was gefunden auf github nennt sich irgendwie lieflet snake oder so das ist eigentlich es
sah eigentlich ganz nice aus das sieht folgendermaßen aus guckt euch mal an so kann man machen
hier allerdings werden wir das nicht so machen weil so eine genaue so eine genaue route haben
wir gar nicht eine genaue route für die router fans unter uns wir werden es eher so machen
also wenn das am ende so aussieht bin ich schon zufrieden
das ist absicht ja das absicht dass ich das nacheinander mache
zumindest jetzt am anfang weil ich weil ich noch nicht mal ein hirn drum herum noch nicht
raus haben wie ich es am besten parallel mache dass die reinfolge am ende stimmt
bietbrot sagt ich glaube was javascript dann auch fehlt ist eine ide als first class citizen
warum vscode ist schon ok das problem ist ein bisschen das javascript so das hohe javascript
auch kacke zu ideen ist im endeffekt warum nicht wie eben erwähnt promise all keine
ahnung weil ich der übelste javascript loop bin keine ahnung
best java ide ist immer noch intelli j beste achso ja das ist auch nice
das ist auch schick das gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut im moment also was ich jetzt gerne
machen würde ist ich nur mal so angemerkt mal gucken wie man das mit promise all machen
was ich jetzt gerne machen würde ist im prinzip einfach nur das da push das da würde ich gerne
machen so und wie machen wir das jetzt mit promise all promise all wie mache ich das
überhaupt würdest du überhaupt machen jetzt
achso also du meinst sowas hier im endeffekt
was geht das war wie gesagt ich bin der übelste javascript loop eigentlich also es hält sich
in grenzen ich meine so die basics so kriege ich hin aber sowas naja gut das ist auch was
wie task weight all oder sowas ne so das müssen wir jetzt gucken ob das funst
ja tatsächlich
da könnten wir es doch moment jetzt jetzt jetzt mal abgedreht jetzt haben wir es mal
abgedreht könnte man da nicht sogar sowas hier machen ich weiß überhaupt nicht ob das
wie das in javascript geht ist nicht select map map ist es dass wir sowas machen irgendwie
sowas da können wir sowas machen ich meine es sieht jetzt zwar nicht schön aus aber
geht das huge das funktioniert ich meine schön ist was anderes aber das ist das ist
nice dass es funktioniert
übrigens war was ist was kreier punkt vorn oder punkt hinten ich mag ja eigentlich punkt
hinten
das gefällt mir das hat was das hat was das mag ich punkt vorn hat es auch da ich mach
bei link meine punkte auch immerhin auch wenn das nicht auch wenn das nicht microsoft best
practice oder sowas ist php gs the fuck was ist das
php ach du scheiße was ist mit den leuten los
das wollte ich gar nicht kopieren ich wollte link kopieren php gs implements php funtions
ach das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht
das ist doch für php leute das ist doch nice
was ist das moment man kann man kann die c standard lib verwenden in in javascript sehe
ich das richtig
ach nee nur die hälfte implementiert na gut ich darf es nicht so sehr sidetracken lassen
jetzt
kennst du ein gutes recovery tool wo ich daten von einer sd karte retten kann gar nicht
wenn die sd karte kaputt ist hast du gelitten also ssds und sd karten recoveren wenn der
controller im arsch ist oder das ding nicht das kannst du vergessen
wenn du die karte noch wenn du die karte noch gelesen kriegst
gute frage also wenn die karte noch an sich funktioniert
ich glaube bei sd karten hat man mit dem recoveren echt schlechte chancen
also ich glaube sd also generell ssds und sd karten recoveren ist
so ein ding da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen
weil das problem beim beim beim recoveren von also sagen wir mal du hast eine magnet
platte und du hast aus versehen was gelöscht so die daten sind noch auf der platte drauf
und du weißt wo sie waren oder sagen wir anders da du hast du hast ein boot record
kaputt gemacht auf einer auf einer magnet platte willst du ihn wieder wieder herstellen
da kannst du dir da kannst du dir sicher sein dass es innerhalb der ersten 512 bytes ist
und die ersten 512 bytes sind auch immer die ersten 512 bytes auf einer magnet platte
also immer bei der sd bei der ssd oder bei der sd karte ist immer die sache wohin wurde
das intern vom controller gemapt das heißt wenn ich jetzt darauf zugreife auf auf sektor
0 heißt es nicht mal dass ich unbedingt auf der gleichen speicherzelle überhaupt rauskomme
wie zu der zeit wo ich die daten gelöscht habe deswegen stelle ich mir ehrlich gesagt
recoveren von sd karten und recoveren von ssds stelle ich mir eigentlich als ein ding
nahezu unmöglich vor achso ok in so einem direktur das dann das da kann ich dir leider
nix das weiß ich nicht habe ich noch nie gemacht habe ich noch nie gemacht weiß ich
weiß ich leider nix zu ok also ich muss sagen das finde ich eigentlich nice so in values
sind jetzt auch wirklich sind jetzt auch wirklich meine meine koordinaten und nicht etwa irgendwelche
übrig gebliebenen promises oder so das sind wirklich die koordinaten das finde ich cool
ich meine das ist zwar vielleicht nicht der schönste aber ich finde ich finde es cool
ich finde es nice der war es nämlich so ok jetzt haben wir unsere punkte und jetzt können
wir also wir haben jetzt die map so und jetzt können wir eine vorschleife machen und die
map bearbeiten point of points und dann enden wir die achso wir müssen erst mal gucken wie
man den kram hier verwenden kann wir malen erstmal was macht er hier der macht einen
error der macht einen error mit koordinaten gut das haben wir schon dann macht eine poli
line das brauchen wir fit bounds das brauchen wir auch ok machen wir erstmal so fit bounds
map also dann dann zoomt er dann zoomt er schon mal auf die richtige stelle dann zoomt
er schon mal auf die richtige stelle das können wir jetzt mal ausprobieren er zoomt
schon mal auf die richtige stelle wo alles reinpasst das ist schon mal sehr nice so
und dann haben wir eine neue neue poli line und dann gucken wir mal ob er das malt auf
die karte richtig marker brauchen wir dann auch gleich noch lab links besser könnte
man das ding ja nicht verwenden so und dann wie malt man den kram auf die map ach hier
map and layer so jetzt sollten wir eigentlich sollte was das jetzt schon das ist ja das
also wenn das jetzt funktioniert wäre das wirklich einfach das ist ja wirklich einfach
die marker sind weg und wir haben ja noch gar keine marker wir haben ja noch gar keine
marker wir müssen ja noch wir müssen ja noch marker wir müssen ja noch marker machen
marker und jetzt haben wir add zur map die marker und dann sollten wir sogar hier marker
drauf haben so nice gucken wir mal ob es zack or huge nice das gefällt mir so lassen wir
mal zu gucken wir mal wie das aussieht bei bar flensburg oh der muss den kram noch klären
warum warum heißt es eigentlich konst in javascript das ist viel zu klassisch ich
hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet dass das javascript mäßig dass es oder oder oder
oder wie auch immer heißt aber das ist ja cool das gefällt mir jetzt müssen wir noch
gucken wie wir den kram lernen können also wie man das über das klären können weil
ansonsten hat man hat man auf einmal wenn man die sachen mehrfach anklickt sich marker
und und sachen drauf der chat heute wieder okay das mit dem klären machen wir gleich
wir probieren das jetzt erstmal mit dem animieren aus also wir haben jetzt wir haben jetzt unsere
bar wir haben jetzt wir haben jetzt marker der macht noch irgendwelche pop ups ja pop
up die flut marker pop aber ich will da drauf klicken können will da drauf klicken können
aha da ich will da drauf klicken können und dann zeigt soll er mir anzeigen na open
müssen wir es nicht dann soll er mir anzeigen was das ist
ach so moment aber das funktioniert ja gar nicht jetzt habe ich ja den namen nicht mehr
an der stelle probieren wir das mal kurz mit pop up aus hallo ein pop up aber jetzt habe
ich ja den namen nicht mehr an der stelle könnte man dann könnte man dann sagen okay
ja ja was kripp groß wie würde ich das jetzt machen ich brauche hier den name passen zu
dem punkt kann man das irgendwie attachen da dran oder so also ich möchte mir die location
mitspeichern zu den mit den jeweiligen koordinaten vielleicht muss ich das doch in so einer ekligen
vorschleife machen da fällt mir jetzt nämlich gerade nichts dazu ein wie ich jetzt wieder
die location an der stelle krieg eine art dictionary ja ja das ist mir schon klar aber
ich weiß nicht wie ich das machen würde an der stelle
der index sollte gleich sein stimmt stimmt ja klar ja klar der index ist gleich ja stimmt
du hast recht ja klar ja klar aber doch noch mal mal eine richtige mal eine richtige vorschleife
oder machen wir oder machen wir hier jetzt aber so kann man auch machen wir könnten auch
eine richtige vorschleife nehmen vor each gibt es auch mit index ernsthaft jetzt
ach das ist das array for each wann benutzt zu konst und wann let wenn du es ändern willst
nachträglich let und wenn du willst wenn du es nur einmal zuweisen willst und ich beende
dann konst was ist das
ist das ja was krippt überrascht einen jeden tag
das geht glaube ich nur dass das gehe
das geht nicht was was ist das jetzt was sehe ich hier überhaupt aber wir können so eigentlich
damit einfach machen eigentlich doppelt eingefischt eigentlich sollten wir es doch eigentlich
sollten wir es doch damit auch machen können meine tastatur diese scheiß korsartastatur
so teuer und die tasten werden doppelt gedrückt so ein drecksting kauft euch den kack nicht
hier das ding kauft euch das nicht kompletter krab ich kann es kann nicht sein es kann nicht
sein dass eine tastatur 175 euro kostet und nach noch nicht mal einem jahr doppelte tasten
anschläge hat wenn man wenn man das drückt und vor allem dann auch noch v dass man steuerung
v drückt dass die kacke zwei dreimal copy pastet wird das geht nicht das geht nicht
heute muss mich gerade mal ein bisschen über meine kacke tastatur auslassen wartet man
hier oder der ist niedlich den nehmen wir so jetzt sind noch ein bisschen größer
jetzt noch ein bisschen größer ich brauche einen großen kackhaufen
ah das ist gut den da nimmer weil ich den ja viel niedlicher finde save shit so und
jetzt reißen wir mal drauf der so unfertigen kram der so unfertigen kram hier baut der
hat es nicht besser verdient kackding kann doch nicht sein 175 euro 175 euro und dann
sind die tasten gehen nicht richtig was ist das für ein kack kauft euch nicht wie gesagt
kauft euch nicht kauft euch irgendwas günstigeres auf der arbeit habe ich für die arbeit habe
ich mir das ding hier gekauft weil unsere unsere unsere tastaturen auf der arbeit weiß
auch weiß ich nicht so sinnvoll weil die tastaturen die wir standardmäßig auf der
arbeit haben sind müll deswegen habe ich mir für die arbeit aber wie oft läuft eigentlich
in solchen chill step collections dieser song der ist in jeder 5 bar drin oder ja also deswegen
habe ich mir das ding gekauft für die arbeit weil unsere billigen logitech tastaturen die
wir da auf der arbeit gestellt kriegen sind totaler krab das ding habe ich mir gekauft
für die arbeit das ist so viel besser als diese komische als diese komische korsart
tastatur die ich ja aber ich meine ok sie hat keine rgb beleuchtung ja sie hat keine
rgb beleuchtung aber sie fühlt sich deutlich besser an und da geht auch nichts kaputt oder
hat doppelte tasten anschläge oder so ein krab was kosten der kram gerade und ist nochmal
60 euro billiger die gibt es mit numblock ohne numblock wie du willst gibt es alle varianten
von ja also ich kann die ducky keyboards nicht pauschal empfehlen weil ich hatte bisher nur
eins und das finde ich aber richtig gut das ist acht stunden am tag naja ok sagen wir
sieben stunden am tag ist das auf der arbeit im einsatz ich muss ja glücklicherweise keine
acht stunden arbeiten sieben stunden am tag ist das auf der arbeit im einsatz funktioniert
top das einzige was ich mir noch gekauft habe ist weil die ist ziemlich laut gummiringe
gummys entscheid sucht was finde ich dann es gibt so es gibt so gummi unterlege ringe
und die habe ich unter die tasten wo ich dazu neige besonders fest drauf zu hauen
welche cherries ich glaube speeds mx das sind irgendwelche roten glaube ich die das
sie hat und die ducky wollen hat glaube ich ganz normal braune so und da habe ich ein
paar ringe drunter gemacht unter die tastatur also beispielsweise auf die numblock enter
taste und auf die backspace taste und das dämpft das ganz ein bisschen
ah hier funktioniert ok dann machen wir das so index dann machen wir das so auch gut funktioniert
achso ja weil javascript aha so und jetzt marker der text vom marker ist ist so wie
naja nicht ganz das funktioniert nicht ganz weil wir filtern hier die die sachen raus
ohne location also so ganz der weiße als letzter schluss ist es noch nicht was wir hier basteln
achso location
einfach zuerst eine variable ja ja das wahrscheinlich das einfachste aber so funktionen die popups
schon mal ja ja ja aber es ist irgendwie so history gleich das da so und dann sagen wir
hier history so und dann nehmen wir hier history und dann ist das auch halbwegs backfrei an
der stelle bei bursch mal wo ich immer noch weiß wenn es ist muss uns der eichler mal
erklären wo das ist dentsburg zack lehrte kessel dorf ok passt funktioniert so jetzt
kommen wir mal zum animieren der ganzen geschichte
aber haben wir schon seit einer woche oder so
das ist doch was für hintergrundmusik pass auf jetzt kommt der gatschi song oder sowas
ja das war ja klar das war ja klar
nein das lasse ich als hintergrundmusik laufen
lieber das da im hintergrund laufen
ist das toll wenn man das im hintergrund laufen lässt weil in battlefield in battlefield kann
man dann zum beispiel in battlefield abfakt macht man das einfach lauter und davon gibt
es das nuptok version ernsthaft zumindest wenn man das game abfakt kann man an dem rythmus
von der musik irgendwelche quickscopes machen so nach dem oder so in der rechte ungefähr
so so kann man dann mal was ihr jetzt gehört hat
so das funktioniert wunderbar wenn man frustriert ist von irgendwelchen games
was es gibt kirby gomu ist nur ernsthaft ich ahne schlimmes leute ich ahne schlimmes
ich ahne schlimmes
es passt überhaupt nicht es passt überhaupt nicht
dann machen wir jetzt schon haftbefehl einziger haftbefehl song den ich kenne
jetzt wir machen jetzt weiter zackiger könnte das ganze sein no vocals no vocals ist gut
no vocals geht mir immer auf den keks auf die abi ok weiter weitermachen muss man irgendwann
auch hinkriegen hier jetzt wisst ihr auch warum ich den warum ich den den kram normalerweise
in letzter zeit eher alleine weiter programmieren einfach weil ich on stream immer nix hinkriege
weil das immer ewig dauert ok also wir haben jetzt geschafft ein strich auf die map zu
malen und die marker miteinander zu verbinden wenn ich das richtig sehe genau so sehr schön
jetzt müssen wir den ganzen kram plus noch animieren dann nehmen wir das hier und suchen
mal ob es uns in irgendeinem cdn gibt perfekt dann mal copy wir brauchen unbedingt wir brauchen
unbedingt ein eigenes javascript ein eigenes css und linksfile guck mal meine index datei
ist 500 zeilen lang so jetzt haben wir den kram eingebunden jetzt animieren wir das mal
wie geht denn das das hier haben wir machen wir auch alles
einfach nur das hier ausführen einfach nur das hier ausführen oder sehe ich das sehe
ich das richtig das alles was man machen muss das wäre omega easy
easy as a fuck guck euch das mal an probieren wir mal hier mit aus flensburg
gemacht ich glaube der kommt mit der mit der meiner mit meinem browser tools da unten nicht
so ganz zurecht cool cool sehr gut das ist alles das ist ja übelst easy hier kann man
die geschwindigkeit noch ein bisschen hoch machen hier ein bisschen langsam der kram
neiking speed 9000 oh der ist vielleicht ein bisschen schnell 500
kann man auch straßenrouten ja dann bräuchte ich eine routing api dann wird es komplizierter
aber ganz ehrlich also ja könntest du machen könntest du machen ja ist kein problem wenn
du die daten von den api kriegst letztendlich für mein paket ist es eh nicht so relevant
weil ich habe doch gar keine ahnung wo der paketboote beziehungsweise wo das paket lang
transportiert wird kann auch sein dass im flugzeug fliegt jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt
wie schnell die animation war die animation ist viel zu schnell oder ach die animation
ist gut oder sagt mal ach der malt ist jetzt oben drüber geht das muss ich noch machen
dass das geklärt wird geklärt wird aber das doch gut dass es gefällt mir so was wir jetzt
noch machen können ist wir können den aktuellen marker machen wir grün also sprich dort wo
der aktuelle stand ist machen wir grün weil aktuell hat man aktuell erkennt man auch
nicht mal ob das paket von da nach da so richtig unterwegs oder von da nach da den aktuellen
marker machen wir noch grün würde ich sagen wo gerade der aktuelle stand ist wäre auch
gut wenn die waypoints erst aufhauen wenn sie von der linie erreicht und jetzt wird's
aber das ist ein popup das ist ein popup guck da wird die seite nicht neu das ist ein popup
das ist nur ein fullscreen popup und das ist absicht weil ich glaube dass ein fullscreen
popup einfach auf mobile einfacher zu verwenden ist der absende ort auch in anderer farbe
ja können wir machen können wir machen also sagen wir mal so wir können sagen ist story
start ist null und ende haben wir nicht wir haben immer nur aktuell aktuell kann ende
sein oder was anderes geht sowas in java script nee oder wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich
geht nur die billig variante irgendwie last element was gibt es dafür schöne varianten
mittlerweile get the last item in array ja minus eins slice minus eins null das ist doch
das remove das array das wollen wir nicht ok nee anscheinend ist das die einfachste
variante dass sowas einfaches noch nicht in java script drinne ist dass man von hinten
arrays indizieren kann was ist was zum teufel ist das hier sieht aus wie den range operator
ist aber kein range operator redi germany doch doch das funktioniert allerdings das
problem ist dass pop den das letzte element entfernt aus dem ursprungs array das will
ich ja nicht ich will ich will es nur referenzieren ich will es ja gar nicht entfernen aus dem
ursprungs array also also da muss doch was einfaches geben ich habe wir könnten jetzt
mal wieder in java script library verwenden die die last funktion hat aber schon merkwürdig
dass es da nix gibt na gut ich mein so kann ich auch mit leben so aber dass es keine first
und last methoden gibt oder den range operator irgendwas das ist schon komisch was ich also
ich was ich ja mag ist so die sachen in ruby oder so zum beispiel wo du einfach so machen
kannst ja eins von hinten das ist das finde ich ist total intuitiv irgendwie total intuitiv
ok der start marker was soll der start marker für eine farbe kriegen also der standard
marker der standard marker wir müssten das übrigens hiermit machen weil wir da mehr
einträge haben der standard marker ist blau also ich würde sagen den den da den hier
den machen wir grün den machen wir grün und den da machen wir kappa pride color ok also
ja ihr könnt euch da alle ein github dran austoben was wenn es nur einen gibt naja wenn
es nur einen gibt und das ist der start dann ist er halt startfarbe und alle dazwischen
sind blau ok also dann muss man jetzt sagen wenn moment
ja also wenn ich beim start beim start marker bin dann machen wir den lila wenn ich beim
was wenn ich beim aktuellen marker bin wenn ich beim aktuellen marker bin dann grün jetzt
muss ich noch gucken wie ich das mache wie ich die wie ich die farben wie ich das einfärbe
das meanboard ist nicht auf github also nicht das aktuelle ich habe mal irgendwann uralt
version davon hochgeladen leaflet leaflet marker color changing marker color leaflet
color markers wie dazu brauchen wir eine extra java script ist echt ein land der 30 millionen
libraries ich hätte jetzt nicht erwartet dass man dass man die farbe von dem marker
nicht ändern kann also green icon haben wir doch hier green icon wir haben abhängigkeiten
zu github sogar mittlerweile drin jetzt muss ich mir alles runterladen und auch in die
anwendung rein packen aber zum testen probieren aus green marker greener marker
und dann so hier das ganze adden bei wie wir das adden ist eigentlich wurscht icon green
icon können wir dahinter schreiben ok also sowas hier das heißt im moment was mache
ich denn schwachsinn wenn der marker current ist dann marker
wie icon set icon set icon set icon klingt doch ganz gut set icon dann wahrscheinlich
so direkt ok wenn das jetzt funktioniert müsste der aktuelle eintrag also flensburg müsste
grün sein funst
der marker ist ein bisschen unglücklich das ist das gefängnis in flensburg
der marker ist ein bisschen unglücklich das sieht so aus als würdest du das gefängnis
von flensburg geliefert ja gut unsere geo api ist der meinung dass flensburg die koordinator
von flensburg ist die flensburger justiz vollzugsanstalt warum nicht warum machst du
nix wenn die geo api das meint und wie machen wir jetzt wie machen wir jetzt ok violet violet
wollen wir haben das heißt wir machen das gleiche noch mal anstatt screen icon machen
wir jetzt violet icon so guck mal ob das jetzt auch funktioniert
habt ihr das gesehen das finde ich das finde ich echt nice das finde ich richtig nice
hier die animation achso das löschen müssen wir noch machen übrigens wir müssen noch
löschen das wenn man die karte wechselt aber ich finde es schick ich finde es echt schick
es hat nicht jemand von euch zufälligerweise sendungsnummer von dpd die dieses jahr also
die noch nicht so alt ist dass sie noch im system ist die mehr als ein stop hatte also
mehr als drei stops also mehr als absender also die mehrere zwischen stops hat also aktuell
haben wir hier drei stück achso ja das stimmt du hast recht
das finde ich echt cool das gefällt mir
das gefällt mir echt gut dass das ist auch so weich irgendwie so was wir jetzt noch machen
müssen wir müssen den kram wegschmeißen den den kram wieder löschen das machen wir folgendermaßen
wir führen mal eine neue variable ein map layer ein array map items oder so ein array
und überall wo ich add layer mache ist map items push machen wir den noch dabei wo ist
der marker wo kommt der marker hin da das geht bestimmt schöner wenn man sich mit
lieflet ein bisschen beschäftigt hat 100 pro und ich würde sagen am anfang wird es einfach
einmal geklärt am anfang wird es einmal geklärt ist das items ist moment ich kann das nicht
klieren lassen ha ha ha ne ne ich kann das nicht klieren lassen versuch die mal ok moment
moment machen wir jetzt leo nicht leo dick warum will ich leo dick dpd sendeverfolgung will
ich haben tracking ne sind auch nur sind auch nur sind sogar nur zwei zwei stationen
ich muss mal was gucken wir müssen mal unsere vm kurz starten karl
wir müssen mal gucken was da als ergebnis von der csv datei kommt
das dpd paketzentrum steht gar nicht drin das ebaro das ebaro hat huge tracking numbers
am start essen wir haben was ne das hat auch nur zwei leitkästen es hat auch nur zwei
das hat sogar nur eins von essen nach essen
ja da hätte man nämlich mal angucken können wie das wie das funktioniert
hätte mich mal interessiert wie es auf der map aussieht wenn es mehr als drei punkte
sind na ja gut ok schön also weiter im text ich wollte den kram löschen lassen
this map remove layer
so mal gucken ob das doch funktioniert er malt den kram hin und jetzt sollte
die sollten weg sein cool hat funktioniert erlöscht den kram wieder aber ich glaube
ich krieg fehler meldung also ich denke mal dass ich fehler meldung krieg wenn ich das
erste mal öffne mach ich nicht achso ja klar weil der kram leer ist doch gut wunderbar
die map unloadet er nicht achso loading steht da oben immer noch das natürlich nichts in
uns weg der übung dass da loading drinne steht am ende oder besser gesagt eigentlich
da können wir nämlich sagen map title map title ist oder steht nämlich auch obendrinne
dann drei burch genau das sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön ich mag das also die animationen
gefällt mir richtig gut wir stylen jetzt noch wir stylen jetzt noch die linie mal die linie
gefällt mir ich hätte gerne so eine punkte linie wirst du ja sowas da sowas hätte ich
gerne
geht nur dpd ja gerade zum testen geht leider nur dpd poly line css wie geht das how to
apply css und poli lines class name my poli line ok das muss natürlich nicht mein poli
line heißen sondern
ach komm winwinwin na mein poli line ist bescheuert poli line ehh anders hier tracking so tracking
line scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll wir brauchen
unbedingt für eigene files da hier tracking line sowas hat er hier für ein beispiel drinne
nehmen wir das einfach mal was der dude hier macht
gucken wie es jetzt ist ah cool das gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut allerdings machen das
nicht grün sondern wir machen das blau jetzt mal gucken oh das ist doch schön oder alter
das ist doch das doch nice da geht mir voll einer ab bei mtc warum kein farbverlauf jetzt
gehts ab ey das machen wir jetzt aber wir machen noch einen farbverlauf
ach so geht das überhaupt geht das überhaupt geht das so
oh wow jetzt wirds aber abgedreht
oh ach du scheiße was mit denen alter was ist mit denen los geht das
ok
kann man kann man nicht einfach sagen
wie ist kommentar in css ach keine ahnung
ich öffne dann color kann man probieren aus color red background color ausprobieren
ok ne das geht nicht das müssen wir mit stroke machen
color ist die text war ja ich dachte es geht geht das geht das vielleicht kann man
das ist mir jetzt busy zu kompliziert ehrlich gesagt wenn ich solche konstrukte hier schon
sehe ich soll ich jetzt mal im anderen browser aufmachen
das raketentest ok leute das ist nicht so einfach wie ich mir das gedacht habe
das ist nicht so einfach wie ich mir das gedacht habe dass wir da noch ein farbverlauf machen
demo
wir könnten noch eine weitere library einbinden dass wir das machen können ja was gibt es echt
das library lande ist ja was leute ich gebe mich mal damit zufrieden ich gebe mich mal
damit zufrieden ist auch schon nice ja so und es sogar man kann sogar drauf klicken
hier und da kriegt man die kriegt man angezeigt was sache ist was mir jetzt natürlich noch
was jetzt so interessant wäre wenn was unterwegs ist dass man angezeigt kriegt wo sein wo der
heimatort ist und wo es gerade ist aber ich habe noch ich habe noch nichts wo da wo die
adresse vom heimatort gespeichert wird drinne das passt nicht eventuell noch urzeit und
datum bei den markern ja das finde ich das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool das finde ich
cool also sprich an der stelle wo wir die marker pop ups machen also da irgendwo hier
so marker pop-up da machen wir nur die location da können wir anstatt location können wir
auch noch übrigens history brauche ich an der stelle doch gar nicht
doch brauche ich
ja entry so da könnte man machen location
und dann machen wir hier die urzeit dahinter also updated ads probieren wir mal aus war
ob das funktioniert macht doch ein postauto dass die linie entlang fährt da müsste ich
ein anderes animationsplan suchen wieso der marker mein factory heißt weil ich es
dran geschrieben habe das hat keinen tieferen grund einfach weil ich es dran geschrieben
habe weil ich wissen wollte wie das aussieht wenn hier noch was steht das paket ist auch
nicht von alternaten das ist auch nicht von amazon oder keine ahnung ich weiß nicht wo
er die eine pakete sind keine ahnung habe ich einfach dran geschrieben
format datetime brauchen wir jetzt
ich ich müsste mal ich müsste mal ein bisschen typescript lernen
was ist das problem ich müsste echt mal ein bisschen typescript lernen weil mir diese
javascript geschichte ein bisschen auf den keks geht dass man immer nicht sieht was man
übergeben übergeben muss und sowas also außer dass man sich selbst manchmal übergeben muss
das ist gut hier das gefällt mir
wir müssen wir müssen ein bisschen ich brauche ein bisschen auf auf halter auf halter musik
es
mittlerweile ist alles hate speech kann es nix machen also wenn das weit zu
primacy ist dann war er ja nicht aber sonst noch hier grad für dire dire doctor das ist eher chillzor
Brauche ich noch monka chill oder so
Okay, nein, danach suche ich nicht das könnte das könnte falsche suchergebnisse bringen
Was was ist halb
Gameboy war das
Gameboy, Game of Music, Hilfe
Gameboy, Game of Music
Gameboy, Musik
Gameboy Musik war halt das war mir auch war sogar mir zu zu zu roh
Gameboy, Game of Music
Also soll ich für mich körper streamen hat es nichts zu tun
Okay, was auch immer
Hier nice
Gameboy, Game of Music
Fällt mir nicht so
Pepe chill
Trau mich immer nicht die bilder aufzumachen hier und streamen
Gameboy, Game of Music
Easy haben wir schon
Okay, ja war
Neuner
Gameboy, Game of Music
Jetzt haben wir die Uhrzeit noch dabei ja also ich muss sagen ich bin jetzt damit ehrlich gesagt schon schon schon recht recht zufrieden ja
Dann hast du siehst du die sachen hier auf einen blick ja das geocoding machen wir machen wir nicht im front end das machen wir
Einmalig beim abrufen der daten und dann haben was den weil ich mein ganz ehrlich so lange wartet doch kein mensch auf eine map bis die
Geo ap sich mal
Breit erklärt uns mal zu antworten
Running law und cuties ja
Kommt wie lahm das ist leute sehen das
Wenn man getrostet ist das ist das geht nicht dass man das jedes mal jedes mal abrufen
Das ist fail das ist fail
Welche map das ist auf dem street maps sind das ist das auf dem street map
Gucken wir das ganze im dark mode aussieht gut halt da
Warum mache ich auch ich mache die abfrage
Sauberseitig und merkt man die einfach einmalig
Aber ich wollte heute eigentlich hauptsächlich mal ausprobieren wie das mit den karten funktioniert und ich muss sagen das funktioniert relativ einfach und
Was was wäre ich mal müssen den kram auf aufsplitten
Wir müssen wir müssen den kram aufsplitten
Also wir müssen den kram aufsplitten dass ich guck mal ich mein
das sind jetzt
550 zeilen javascript nicht stimmt nicht 550 zeilen wildeste mischung javascript html und css
mein css sagt wahrscheinlich auch
Hardcore ja allein schon die includes da oben er kommt euch das mal an
Das ist doch nicht normal
Aber ich bin zufrieden damit also ich finde das ist das ist sehr nice da für das dass die map eigentlich nur mal so als gimmick geplant war
Ich finde es wirklich cool
Ich überlege mir nämlich gerade normalerweise ist es ja so eine sache das sind keine straßenrouten natürlich nicht
Straßenrouten wäre auch kein
Sagen wir mal kein allzu grosses ding
Weil man kriegt
Man kriegt von open street maps die haben eine routing ap
Die haben eine routing ap
Dann kann ich durch die
Wo ist die Musik? Die ist einfach nur leise.
Wo sind denn die Docs dazu?
Ich finde es jetzt gerade nicht.
Ich hatte heute Vormittag etwas gefunden.
Oh, Pock, Twitch Prime, der M11 Bro. Dankeschön Pock.
Ups, falsches. Dankeschön Pock.
Ich finde es jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr. Ich hatte heute Mittag etwas Gutes gefunden.
Da konnte man sich Routen berechnen lassen.
Genau, Curl, Leaflet. Es war ein Beispiel für Berlin drin.
Weiß ich noch.
Ich finde es nicht mehr.
Ja, das da, genau.
Das da, bloß nicht zum Selbsthosten, sondern schon fertig gehostet.
Wie weit ist das Tool? Guck mal hier. Wir können jetzt mittlerweile sogar schon Routen
malen.
Guck mal, Huge Pock. Wir sind ein bisschen gedrosselt.
Ist es nicht was?
Da ist das Paket aktuell und da ist es losgefahren.
Hier, das da habe ich gesucht, genau. Damit kann man Routen bauen.
Zum Beispiel hier, Route mit dem Auto. Was ist denn, OFP Ik Dings, bla, blub.
Was ist das da für eine Magic, ey?
Was ist das hier für satanistische Textketten?
Hier ist irgendwie, ist das Base, nee, das kann auch kein Base64 sein.
Weiß nicht, was es ist.
Weil ansonsten kriegt man das in dieser Form.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr. Da hat man quasi die Route drinnen.
Ich meine, das könnte man ausprobieren.
Wir könnten eine Route berechnen und das dann einfügen.
Aber das ist ehrlich gesagt ziemlich sinnlos.
Es braucht unnötig Zeit, das ist im Hintergrund noch mal zu berechnen.
Und die Sache ist die, wir haben doch eh keine Ahnung, wo das Auto lang fährt.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, wo das Auto lang fährt, von der Post.
Ihr wisst es nicht.
Wie geht es der Katz, der Katakatz, geht es gut.
Service, Version, Profile, Koordinat, Koordinat, String of Format, Polyline.
Ach, Moment, das hier ist die Polyline, wozu das mein Routing generiert.
Ach so, das ist nicht, dass ich mich in der Polyline so verstehe.
Also im Prinzip könnte ich mir jetzt hier sowas generieren lassen.
Und dann müsste ich mir quasi selbst die Stops rausparsen und davon eine Polyline basteln.
Das ist mir der Aufwand nicht wert, ehrlich gesagt.
Und es bringt ja nichts, weil wie gesagt, wir haben keine Ahnung, wo das Postauto langfährt.
Und es interessiert ehrlich gesagt auch niemand.
Die Leute wollen wissen, wo ihr Paket ist, und das Paket ist halt nur mal da seit 26.07.
Katzencam, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die gerade ist.
Leaflet Animate Icon, ich will mal gucken, ob von den Polybar.
Weißt du, was ich gerne hätte?
Nein, nein, ich warte nicht seitdem.
Was noch cool, was noch nice wäre, wenn hier so ein Postauto langfahren würde.
Das wäre doch witzig, oder?
Das heißt, wir brauchen ein Plugin, das einen Icon an der Polybar langfahren lassen kann.
Demo, Demo, ja, ja, so was, genau.
Ui, so was da.
Okay, wie geht das jetzt?
Motion, Polyline, okay, Moment, wie verwendet man den Kram jetzt?
Demo, haben wir eine Demo?
Lass mal nämlich echt so ein Auto langfahren, doch, ja, so, so, okay, das will ich jetzt
noch mal ausprobieren.
Das wäre lustig, da war man nämlich den Krempel hier mal wieder weg, aber das da weg, das
ist ja im Prinzip alles, was wir haben und anstatt der Polyline machen wir mal das Ding.
Das probieren wir mal aus, ob es funktioniert, wenn es nicht funktioniert, ist auch okay.
Was wird denn hier gebastelt?
Guck mal, Moment, ich muss mal rückgängig machen, dass ich das zeigen kann.
Wo waren wir hier?
Wir haben unseren Versandtracker ein bisschen aufgebohrt, dass er jetzt gucken kann, wo
das Paket gerade ist.
Wir müssen den Kram übrigens noch einbinden, fällt mir gerade auf, Leaflet-Motion, okay,
da binden wir mal ein, bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert mit dem Auto animieren,
das wäre, das wäre huge, nice, okay, also wir haben den Kram jetzt so angelegt, wie
er das gerne hätte, Polyline, da müssen wir, hier kommen unsere Points rein, so und wie
geht das jetzt weiter, Moment, wo habe ich, wo habe ich die Seite, blick nicht mehr durch,
so viele Browser, so viele Browser, der Igor, wie auch immer, ja, Amazon hat das drinne,
Amazon DPD hat das auch, mir geht es hauptsächlich darum zu gucken, wie man das macht und der,
also warum, also warum ich überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen bin, ist, dass es keinen
Paket-Tracker gibt, den man selbst toasten kann, der alles kann, was ich will, zum Beispiel
hätte ich gerne, dass das Ding in meinem E-Mail-Postfach guckt und meine E-Mails untersucht, ob da Tracking-Nummern
drin sind und dann automatisch die Tracker hinzufügt, also und auf allem so, dass das
jeder selbst bei sich laufen lassen kann, dass der dann sagt, okay, ich würde gerne
zwei E-Mail-Postfächer untersuchen lassen, woran er sich halt registriert hat bei Shops,
man guckt das Ding in den E-Mail-Postfächern nach, es gibt eine neue Tracking-E-Mail, fügt
es automatisch hinzu und benachrichtigt mich dann im Zweifelsfall auch darüber, wenn ein
Paket kommt, oder kann ich da meine Heimautomatisierung ordentlich integrieren, gibt es den, also ich
habe in der Richtung nichts gefunden, vor allem, vor allem nichts, was man selbst toasten
kann.
So, add to map, wie geht es, wie, wie geht das jetzt, also die Beispiele von der, von
der Library sucken, ich glaube das machen wir jetzt doch nicht, die schmeißer wieder raus,
da blickst du ja überhaupt nicht durch, was du machen sollst.
Es gibt eine Parcel-Track-RP, aha, also Parcel-Track kenne ich, also von denen habe ich mir auch
schon mal die App angeguckt, ob die eine Public API haben, bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich vorstelle, die wollen ja nicht ihr Zeug rausrücken.
Parcel-Track-API, nö, nö, gibt es nicht, ich meine, Aftership, Aftership gibt es nicht,
Aftership kenne ich, aber das bringt ja doch, das bringt doch auch nicht wirklich was.
Da hast du eine API, wo du die Sachen abfragen kannst, ja, aber ich kann die, ich kann die
auch vom Hersteller direkt abfragen, das ist ja auch okay, solange sie eine API haben,
allein damit hast du jetzt ja auch noch nicht großartig gewonnen.
Oh, habe ich Subscriber übersehen, Master Domtival, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, POG,
ich verklick mich, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime, POG, huge.
Wow, fuck, das funktioniert einfach, habt ihr das gesehen, das funktioniert einfach.
Huge, sehr nice, ich meine, jetzt muss ich natürlich noch einen Icon auswählen, ja,
es hat einen Haken, cool, also, wenn es dann drei Stunden später mal geladen hat.
Okay, also da müssen wir jetzt noch einstellen, natürlich, was das Ding, die Optik, die Optik
von dem Ding, ähm, Class, ja, ich glaube, Tryout, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja.
Ich glaube, Truck hieß das Ding einfach nur, ach fuck, wie hieß das Ding nochmal, kann
ich schon nachgucken.
Airport Shuttle, das heißt nicht einfach Truck, sondern wie es nahe liegen kann, das heißt
Airport Shuttle.
Also da fährt's auto
Ist ja lustig
Blumen 2000 keine Arbeit die letztens was bestellt haben es wird gerade so eingefallen
Das ist ja schick was wir noch gucken dass die dass die dass die zeile
Duration
Color kann man mal gucken ob es dann auch da bleibt
Ui
Und es verschwindet auch nicht aber das ist ja cool
Das ist ja cool
Aber blau das ganze
Das ist für die schick ich
Ich kann sei
Ich kann es jetzt auch einstellen dass das auto
Kann man auch einschalten dass das auto irgendwie durchsichtig ist oder so
Ich finde das nice das hat irgendwie was
Irgendwie hat das was
Ich finde schick
Gut ja so viel hat
Jetzt müssen wir doch gucken wie man hier
Hier poliline poliline müssen wir noch noch einstellen dass wir
Classname wo wir haben
Da kann man nämlich die color weg machen
Und dann sieht das sieht das wieder
Ui jawohl jetzt haben wir unsere linie aber das ist auch cool das gefällt mir das ist das ist nice
Ich mag es das auto nahe macht ja ich bin ich finde das nice das ist das gefällt mir richtig gut
Nice das das das ist noch besser als das andere oder
Ising was was wird da geist
Ach das ist dass es gleich schnell ist
Duration braucht zu lange auch zu lange
Ja so ist besser das dauert braucht sonst zu lange jetzt mache aus dem auto den repairer
Mal ich mal gucken was passiert wenn ich da mein dhl mein dhl icon in den hintergrund mache
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool da könnte ich quasi fahren lassen je nachdem was es für einen anbieter
Ist ich meine das braucht noch ein bisschen css optimierung ja
Aber ich finde ich finde es mit dem auto ich finde es mit ich finde es mit dem auto schicker
gefällt mir irgendwie besser
Tracking icon mal gucken was wir da noch machen können css mäßig
Tracking icon
Dann haben wir mal background kolore transparent
Ist auch nicht transparenter als vorher
Kann man das hier überhaupt beeinflussen kann man das damit auch beeinflussen ja doch man kann es beeinflussen
Man könnte auch sowas hier sagen wie kann
Na gut was soll man da eigentlich groß machen ich meine das auto das auto sieht doch sieht
doch ganz okay aus
Ich mag das echt mir gefällt das wir stellen das noch mal kurz hier ein bisschen um
Und zwar mal irgendwie auto true
RGB truck setzt alpha auf null
So kann man mal ausprobieren wo haben wir es denn hier background color rgba
Keine Ahnung was waren wir da null null null
So nicht dass ich da groß wüsste was ich mache
Oder ist eins eins ist komplett transparent oder null kann man sich mal nicht merken
Null ist transparent
Dachte das klappt hier dachte ich auch aber es könnte sein
Dass man hier mal gucken müssen wie man css mäßig was
Da bestimmt irgendwas drum herum
Und dann ist es nämlich unterschiedlich lange wobei die duration ist besser
Dann fährt es schneller auf langen routen und kürzer und langsamer bei
Jetzt habe ich ihn hier oben gelöscht
Das da hatte ich gerade gelöscht
Oder ich muss gleich Schluss machen ich kann er nicht mal ich kann er nicht mal draufgucken
Ach Quatsch muss da rein
Wenn wir jetzt getrosselt sind wollen wir zu viel Zeug abfragen
Das ist einfach am marker stehen das Auto
Ich bin begeistert mit dem Auto das gefällt mir wirklich gut
Ich könnte mir die animation noch den restlichen Abend angucken
Das ist super nice und relativ simpel ne
Loop die einfach genau kann man das
L-Motion Sequence
Da kann man kann man verschiedene sachen machen
Aber ehrlich gesagt einmal einmal autofahren ist genug
Zack zack das gefällt mir das lassen wir so
Genug geproggers
Wenn ihr einen amazon prime account habt könnt ihr das ganze kostenlos verknüpfen
Und ihr könnt damit einmal im monat kostenlos einen streamer eurer wahl unterstützen
Ich mache mal aus ja ich mache den mal aus genug proggers reicht mir als gut vor allem
genug javascript auf amazons nacken genau
Man startet eigentlich noch mal die modern warfare beta
Startet die beta
Ach da ps4 exklusiv das ist sowas so woodface
PS4 exklusiv
Warum muss es ps4 exklusiv sein ich hab kein bock ps4 zu spielen
So mal ich hab ja sogar auch nur nur eine normale ps4 da läuft das wahrscheinlich nichtmal
ordentlich drauf
Oh jojo das ist gut
Das läuft bestimmt auf einer ps4 pro und auf der normalen ps4 läuft wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut
Ich kauf mir keine ps4 mehr ich hab die ich hab zur release beides gekauft und nie verwendet
warum sollte ich mir eine pro kaufen total rausgeschmissenes geld
Zumal es nächstes jahr eine ps5 gibt wahrscheinlich
Ihr gebt ihr überhaupt keinen sinn
Also wahrscheinlich spielen wir es dann erst hier ne
Ach ja und pre-ordern werden wir sofern man es zurück geben kann
Wir gucken mal kurz was auch wenn ich mit denen nichts mehr zu tun hab
Ich konsent ich konsente hier zu gar nichts G2A
Dann müssen wir amazon bestellen
Die vertreiben den kram für pc gar nicht mehr
Anscheinend meinen die das ernst wenn man vorbestellt kann man es diesmal nicht mehr
zurückgeben
Tjaa
Dark Edition
Was kostet denn die mw2 dark edition äh mw4
200 Euro
Ein schnapper
easy
200 Euro das ist ja fast geschenkt
Warum hat eigentlich warum ist es eigentlich notwendig jetzt wo ich gerade das bild hier
sehe
Warum ist es eigentlich notwendig dass eine open beta die nicht open ist wohlgemerkt
Ähm warum warum hat die warum warum gibt es da vier verschiedene start zeitpunkte
Weil das hier ist nicht open und das hier ist auch nicht open im prinzip gibt es wirklich
für open beta nur zwei starts es gibt es nur gibt es nur zwei sachen ps4 am 14 und pc
am 21
So fail
Lässt doch schon mal erahnen lässt doch schon mal erahnen was da noch an alles auf
uns zukommt in dem game
Das ist das ist richtig beat bro das ist ja nicht stimmt ja du hast recht es ist noch
nicht mal eine beta und open ist sie auch nicht
Eine beta machst du nicht drei Wochen vor dem release
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn warum sollte man eine beta drei Wochen vor dem release mal
Das ist das ist im prinzip eine demo
Das ist im prinzip eine demo
Kommt das kommt das auf steam
Das kommt bestimmt nicht auf steam das kommt bestimmt nur im blizzard launcher
Wie kann man den blizzard
Ja ist klar wenn ich die beta gespielt habe und sage refund please dann sagen die fick
dich please
Wie könnte man das hinkriegen
Eee battle royale geh weg
Was gibt es da wieder digital standard
Operator edition
Operator enhanced
Was ist da wieder für ein krempel dabei
Digital ist das game operator edition hat was custom in game tactical knife braucht kein
mensch
Operator pack crew apps das sind irgendwelche irgendwelche skins oder so
Prestige token in black ops 4 viel billiger können sie das
Captain price blackout charakter in black ops brauche auch kein mensch
Call of duty points oh Gott es geht wieder los
Hör mal auf hör mal auf mit dem scheiß
Ok was was was kostet das mehr im vergleich
Was kostet das mehr
Ihr habt doch nicht mehr alle tassen im schrank
40 euro 40 euro für ein bisschen digitaler digitaler
Stumpfsinn 40 euro mehr für für für nix
Den kram gibt es ja überall
Das einzige was es hier gibt ist irgendwelche operators packs
Und hier gibt es doch gott points dazu
Meine güte ist das eine eine gemelkerei
Wie stehst du zu borderlands 3
Ich hab mir noch nicht angeguckt großartig
War gott eigentlich immer so schlimm oder wurde es so
Es wurde immer schlimmer eigentlich man hat sich ja schon seit je
Seit je her wie sagt man seit seit ja und tag oder seit tag und ja
Aber schon schon immer hat man sich da drüber aufgeregt oder lustig
gemacht wie sellout activation ist
Die sache ist die dass es jedes jahr jedes jahr ist es mehr geworden
Und das liegt daran weil die leute mitmachen wenn die leute nicht mitmachen
Dann wird es auch nicht weniger weil dann wird es versucht
Auf anderen wegen zu machen so dass es die leute nicht merken
Video mit haptik in planung bisher nicht wie kommst denn da drauf
Ich glaube ich hatte mit haptik noch nie großartig irgendwas zu tun
Wie kommst du jetzt ausgerechnet auf ihn
Also das also wir sind uns mal auf der gamescom so zwei sekunden über den
Weg gelaufen ich glaube dass er das war
Da war noch nicht so groß ich habe keine ahnung ob er das ich glaube das war er
Ich glaube das war er
Aber ansonsten hat ich mir nie was zu tun großartig
Aber wenn ich wenn ich mal wirklich wieder anfangen sollte ordentlich
Videos zu machen auf youtube
Dann werde ich auf jeden fall die übelste cross promo action machen ja
Dann laber ich sie alle an dann dann haue ich sie alle an
Ob wir nicht videos zusammen machen wollen
Weil nur so kommst du wieder back ins business
Ich habe den vorteil ich meine ich kenne wenigstens noch ein paar leute von
Von der von der ganzen geschichte
Und nachdem ich mich auch nie mit jemand groß gebieft habe
Oder und ich halt auch schon aktiv war wo viele von denen jetzt richtig groß sind
Quasi noch im fanboy alter waren
Denke ich hätte ich auch ganz gute chancen dass da der ein oder andere sagt
Ja max auf geht's lass mal video machen
Ich meine ich suche mal natürlich aus mit wem vorher also gibt leute da würde
sich das abo mäßig bestimmt lohnen aber da habe ich nicht so viel bock drauf
Aber das ist eh zukunft musik weil youtube technisch habe ich gerade nichts geplant
Außer dass ich mir schon seit anfang eines jahres überlege wie ich ordentlich
Technik videos auf youtube machen kann die mainstream genug sind dass es die
leute mögen
Video mit bibi klar easy
Wobei ich ja duggie besser finde als bibi ich mal sagen
Macht auch garten wieder easy zwei millionen views
Drei abos
Naja wenn es drei prime abos sind da bin ich sofort dabei
Was wurde eigentlich aus dem dachboden aufzug der ist weg
Der musste weg weil man das dach isoliert haben komplett und da konnte
es halt kein loch für den fahrstuhl da lassen
Wie viele subs hast du jetzt ich gucke mal
158 aber das hat noch nicht aktualisiert da müssten wahrscheinlich doch doch
Es hat aktualisiert es hat aktualisiert 158 nee es hat doch noch nicht
Aktualisiert die von eben sind noch nicht dabei also wahrscheinlich 160 oder sowas
Das ist huge nie gedacht dass ich so viele krieg aber jetzt bin ich bin ich
Natürlich scharf drauf jetzt muss ich immer sehr laut machen
Riesel regelmäßiger sehr laut wie glaubst du steigt man am besten ins
programmieren ein will nicht extra einen kurz an die uni nehmen um einen
schnitt verdauen versauen am besten ist du hast irgendein
Projekt im kopf was du selber haben willst also wenn du jetzt zum beispiel
sagst keine an mir gehts immer auf den keks dass ich was weiß ich
Die beschwerde bei der bahn immer manuell über den webformular einreichen
will ja und du programmierst dann irgendwas was das für dich machen kann
an ist schon mal die motivation dahinter da als ein blödes beispiel ja aber am
besten ist du hast schon in dem projekt was du gerne umsetzen willst und dann
würde ich sogar sagen suchst du einfach die die sprache raus die sich am besten
eignen würde für dieses projekt also wenn zum beispiel wenn zum beispiel web
geschichte ist dann bleibt ja nicht viel übrig außer dass hat im java
skriptmäßig zu machen wenn es eine windows desktop anwendung ist bleibt er
nicht viel zumindest über als dir mal zumindest dort net anzugucken gibt
natürlich sich andere varianten desktop anwendung zu machen ja würde ich
gucken ich würde gucken dass ich ein projekt ein projekt habe oder ein
projekt oder irgendwas was mich stört programmieren könnte
hat man vor allem auch schon die passende motivation dazu wenn man wenn
man was wenn man so ein ziel hat was man machen will
ja da bietbrot genau so was ist es im endeffekt eine freundin programmiert
zum beispiel könnte man heutzutage mit nimmt man sich irgendwie ein passendes
machine learning framework und dann könnte er loslegen leute
ja und was ich auch empfehlen kann ist wenn du dir was überlegt hast was du was
du machen willst heutzutage 2019 hat man ja mehrere
möglichkeiten aber trotzdem würde ich gucken dass ich mir ein buch hole weil
es einfach angenehmer ist was was gut strukturiertes in der muttersprache zu
lesen dazu würde ich mir die würde ich mal ein paar leute suchen auf youtube die
ordentliche videos zu der jeweiligen sprache machen allerdings man sollte sich
nicht zu sehr mit diesen ganzen tutorial geschichten aufhalten man kann immer mal
wieder eins gucken vor allem zu einem thema wenn man was spezielles wissen
will aber ansonsten guckt man den halben tag tutorials und lernt nix dabei weil
man muss es letztendlich machen dass man lernt ja es sieht mir doch bei mir immer
wie ich am anfang rum krebse mit css und javascript und immer wenn ich da eine
weile was mit gemacht habe da geht es immer besser dann mache ich mal wieder
eine weile nix und dann kriegt kacke ich wieder ab
ja
und ich ich persönlich ich will nicht sagen dass es schlecht ist aber ich
persönlich habe noch nie irgendwie in den kurs in den kurs gebucht bei
irgendeiner bei in der online seite bei in dem online kurs habe nie gebucht
wie gesagt ich habe mir bisher immer entweder habe ich habe ich was gelesen
dazu was auch immer gut ist ist wenn man sich halt konferenz talks anguckt von
aktuellen ereignissen was die jeweilige programmier sprache das jeweilige
framework so aus dem umkreis ist auch immer ganz interessant da sieht man
nämlich auch gleich wie man es richtig macht also wie man das modern benutzt
ja in c sharp sind ein paar ältere sachen da drin sind drinne die man nicht
mehr verwenden sollte aber ganz schlimm ist c++ c++ 100 prozent von den c++
also von von allen c++ sachen ist es mittlerweile so dass man 50 prozent
eigentlich gar nicht mehr verwenden soll weil es die präge das c++ ist ist so die
müllhalde der programmier sprachen easy gibt es noch den fisch da ja die gibt
da sind sogar sind sogar fische gegen c++ genau dann habe ich noch meine vielen
pp emotes das geht ja überhaupt nicht das ist gleich als gleich die anzeige
raus ja das stimmt c++ javascript ist ähnlich javascript ist ähnlich aber ich
glaube es kommt immer noch nicht an c++ dran was was die müllhalde angeht kennt
jemand von euch ein tutorial für modernes javascript ohne sich auf
angular react festzulegen also auf angular oder react musst du dich ja
überhaupt nicht festlegen ich würde da ganz ehrlich da würde ich
mir ein buch ich würde mir tatsächlich ein buch holen würde ich paar reviews
lesen ich würde mir ein buch holen wenn ich modernes javascript lernen will wenn ich
gar keine ahnung hätte wohlgemerkt wenn ich mich schon mit programmier sprachen
an sich auskenne würde ich einfach auf youtube modern javascript webcast
gucken und dann wüsste ich bescheid
ich würde mich auch nicht auf react oder angular festlegen wie gesagt ich bin ja
normalerweise nicht so der frontend frontend mensch aber immer jetzt für
für mein zeug hier ein bisschen und ich komme mit vue js mit abstand am besten
klar das ist viel einfacher oder viel viel einsteiger freundlicher als als als
angular und sowas was ich auch mal vor jahren ausprobiert hat war ember
allerdings ist ember übelst kompliziert im vergleich im vergleich zu view
aber es ist auch schon ein paar jahre älter
wie ist deine erfahrung mit looking class war looking class die die neue
dieses neue gui zeug von microsoft ich bringe das immer durch dann haben diese
diese
diese wie hieß es
nie das war was anderes das hieß anders ach looki für kvm ach das
ne looking class ist die geschichte mit shared memory für für grafikausgabe
ja genau das da ist das herr herr habe ich gerade durch nachher gebracht
ich kann ja aber leider keine oben in meiner lesezeit tatsächlich
lul omg lul ich habe es aber noch nie richtig auf die probe gestellt
eine coole sache ist es auf jeden fall
allerdings frage ich mich so ein bisschen wo der anwendungszweck ist wenn ich eine
vm zum spielen mache wenn ich auf jeden fall nicht verwenden
wenn man ja vielleicht vielleicht für anwendung ja für anwendung oder wenn ich
halt in den browser ordentlich verwenden will ohne dass ich extra monitor
anschließen will dann ist wahrscheinlich ganz gut wenn ich quasi nicht in ein
wenn ich nicht in eigenem monitor dran verwenden will also für spiel würde ich
nicht verwenden also vielleicht für single player spieler aber das ist eher
was für desktop anwendung denke ich mal
aber es ist cool also die idee ist nice
wir haben uns ja letztens zettel gerade jemand was von c++ 20 schreibt wir haben
uns ja letztens die änderung von c++ 20 angeguckt da waren beispiele drinne da
habe ich noch nicht mal verstanden was das beispiel überhaupt macht da war
eben ein beispiel drinne für für irgendwelche neuen template funktionen
die jetzt drin sind wie gesagt ich habe nicht im ansatz mal kapiert was dieses
beispiel überhaupt machen sollte
der spaceship operator zum beispiel genau das spaceship operator
haben wir uns nicht im stream sogar angeguckt
das da
konstrain und konzept irgendwie sowas war das ja irgendwie sowas wo ich dann
gesagt habe alle jetzt jetzt hört es echt auf
aber das war nicht das das beispiel war doch viel wir sind ja bei c++ sind sie
immer der meinung wenn sie neues konstrukt für eine sprache brauchen
lass uns mal ein zeichen nehmen was möglichst oft schon verwendet wird so wir
würden gerne neues konzept einbauen wir haben nur noch 580 verschiedene zeichen
die wir verwenden können und nicht doppelt belegt sind lass uns mal und oder
störnchen nehmen beste idee oder besser gesagt ja
also c++ ist einfach mittlerweile so die müllhalde der programmier sprachen
also was geht mit der musik jetzt gerade ab
muss man mal speichern da ist ganz leis vor allem weil das keine keine
walkers hat keine walkers ist ist huge
speichert das dann auch in china speichert das fack er soll es gar nicht
in china speichern das war für meine schiene einkaufsliste
habe ich eigentlich schon gezeigt dass meine 50 usb kabel angekommen sind
schon vor zwei wochen oder so und ratet mal wie viele
wie viele von meinen 50 usb kabel habe ich schon verwendet
zweiter wie viel kabel ich davon schon verwendet habe
das ist baro kennt mich halt ich habe noch keines davon verwendet gar keins
die liegen alle noch genauso da aber hauptsache 50 usb kabel bestellen
hast du schon getestet ich habe mal eins dran gemacht das ging
spricht nicht für die qualität der anderen aber ich wollte mal zumindest
einmal ausprobieren was hast bezahlt nicht viel 45 euro
oder so inklusive versand inklusive also ich habe weniger als ein euro bezahlt
pro usb kabel inklusive versand und die dinger sind eigentlich auch ganz gut
den usb ist in mikro usb kabel mit einem usb man sieht es ja hier mikro usb mit
einem usb c aufstecker das heißt man kann die jetzt verwenden und in zukunft
verwenden für alles was man so braucht
es ist nicht geschäft des lebens das ist täglicher täglicher aliexpress china
wahnsinn dass der kram so billig ist gibt es immer noch auf aliexpress war
nicht genau die sondern ein bisschen andere aber das macht ja nichts aber
usb kabel meter lang usb mikro usb usb c was hältst du eigentlich von dem anime
face generator tool meinst du meinst du den den
das mal den da
das person das not exist genau und den gab es auch als weep version an die nase
sieht von ihm irgendwie nicht so ganz richtig aus des waifu does not exist war
das doch
ja ja ja ich trau mich es nicht aufzumachen leute
funktioniert ja für unsere ganzen anime fans
maschine learning generierte grills
und das ist nicht einfach ausgeschnitten irgendwie das sind live live generierte
quasi gesichter oder wie live weiß ich wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen
gecasht du hast ja nicht auch zu den anime fernsten ich gucke eigentlich kaum welche
was eine sache gibt die also von von serien ja eine sache gibt die ich mir
tatsächlich angucken wollte das ist die neuauflage von wie ist das full metal
alchemist wollte ich mir neuauflage angucken weil ich habe damals den die die die erste
die erste serie geguckt die quasi noch gemacht wurde als als das die die
vorlage noch quasi gar nicht fertig war da wollte ich mal gucken wie das jetzt
eigentlich richtig abläuft aber das ja auch schon wieder ein paar jahre alt
aber ansonsten guck guck kaum was wenig
ich habe gestern links hier geguckt battle angel aber die die rl verfilmung
das hier fand ich ganz gut das ist eindeutig für leute die ein bisschen
jünger sind also leute die schon mit computer spielen und sachen aufgewachsen
sind ich glaube nicht dass jemand der so auf die der so ein bisschen auf wie
sagt man so ja so ein bisschen klassisch ihre film besteht das dem das gefällt
aber ich fand den film nice ich meine sie hätten den herzschmerz ein
bisschen zurückfahren können sie hätten den herzschmerz ein bisschen
zurückfahren können aber ich will euch jetzt ja nicht nicht spoilern
zwar ein bisschen zu viel teeny teeny love geschichte mit drin also es war
schon nicht schlecht aber es war ein bisschen viel ja
es gibt doch viele filme wo halt immer ein guckt euch mal
natürlich haben wir monka tos hier monka tos ich meine was war diese ganz was
waren diese ganzen komischen twilight filme das war doch auch teeny love story
nur dass es halt vampir und werwölfe waren und nicht irgendwelche cyborgs
wobei die japaner halt eher auf cyborgs stehen als auf vampir und werwölfe
ja heute haben wir richtig viel gestreben sorter drei stunden heute morgen drei
stunden oder wie lange waren wir heute morgen ordentlich muss gerade mal gucken
heute morgen waren wir auch drei stunden und ja passt
ok leute wir sehen uns ich gehe jetzt mal auf bis dann macht's gut
zu